- Why, what's wrong?
I don't see what's wrong!
(bouncy music)
I'm really excited about wearing sarees.
- I have absolutely no
idea how this works.
- No, I didn't.
- [Right] Okay, me neither.
- I'm going to do it in 30 seconds.
- I think that one's mine.
- No, wait, it matches with this color.
- This here is called a petticoat.
- Is this supposed to go from up or down,
because this is, this is quite confusing.
- They go before the saree comes on.
This is going to make
a lot of people happy.
- This is really long.
- It's amazing, man.
Like, just look at all the color.
- What are you supposed
to do with this bit?
- I'm supposed to pleat it, yes.
- You just have to learn how to fold this,
I guess, around you?
- Okay, so you basically
wrap yourself like a mummy.
- I told you I was good at this.
An now, now it's simple.
Now you just do this.
I'm ready.
I'm not finding anything wrong with this,
but I'm just being told that this is
not the right, what, this,
I think this is how you do it, right?
- Where did we go wrong?
(laughs)
- Okay, thank you.
- [Woman] Do this again.
- No, I--
- I don't want to decide
anything, just tell me what to do.
- Life's important decisions.
- Tuck what in?
- Watch and learn, you're
going to pleat this.
No, don't ruin it, don't ruin it.
(laughter)
- (beep) man, how do women manage?
- (mumbles) I have no clue why this goes
like, only over one shoulder, you know.
- What do I do with this now?
- [Voiceover] Tuck it in.
- Ugh, like this.
- [Voiceover] Don't just crumple it up.
- How am I crumpling it up?
These are elegant pleats.
- [Left] I don't think
I can do any better.
- [Right] Good!
- Good! (laughs)
- Guys, I think this is my final form.
- What do you guys make of it, huh?
Yeah?
- [Voiceover] In all fairness,
I can see how much effort
women take into getting ready.
- How do you guys go to pee?
Like, if you wear a saree, do you not,
do you hold yourself for, like 12 hours?
I don't know.
- Because that pleats thing is (beep) up.
Like, that is some messed up (beep).
I have no idea how people do that.
That can't even be mastered.
Like, that's an art of a thing itself.
- Every woman looks beautiful in a saree.
- This is the real way it's
supposed to have been worn.
- We're so bad at it.
- Quite evidently.
I love you, Mom.
- You are naked from
the front there, dude.
- No, I'm wearing a blouse.
- That's fine if you have only one boob.
(bouncy music)